david bonjour vous êtes donc place de la
république pour le traditionnel défilé
du 1er mai qui devrait pas tarder à
partir
effectivement on ira alors moi j'ai
suivi le cortège de la cnt de la
confédération nationale des travailleurs
qui est parti de la place des fêtes pour
se rendre jusqu'ici place de la
république avec un seul objectif pour ce
syndicat révolutionnaire lutter contre
eux l'offensive 1 patronal mais
également mettre en exergue en exergue
l'égalité et la transformation sociale
voilà l'objectif premier de ce syndicat
je me trouve également actuellement avec
céline verzeletti à la secrétaire
confédérale de la cgt céline
merci de répondre à nos questions en
premier mais plus qu'important puisque
l'année dernière on imagine beaucoup de
frustration ne pas avoir pu défiler à
cette année non seulement c'était
important d'être là mais aussi mettre le
mettre en exergue les inégalités que
creuse la crise sanitaire
oui tout à fait en est vraiment content
heureux ça fait vraiment chaud au coeur
de pouvoir se retrouver tous et toutes
déjà dans les rassemblements qui je le
rappelle sont énormément important
aujourd'hui et cette année puisqu'il ya
à peu près 300 rassemblements sur tout
le territoire donc ça c'est déjà un bon
signal et comme vous le dites
en effet la crise l'année qu'on a passée
a été très difficile est très difficile
pour pour les salariés les travailleurs
les travailleuses les précaires les
privés d'emploi les retraités et en
effet cette épidémie et cette pandémie
et la façon dont le gouvernement a géré
cette crise sanitaire a mis en lumière
les inégalités et l'injustice sociale et
à main ne fait exploser un peu plus
justement les inégalités sociales et les
injustices sociales donc bien évidemment
il faut qu'on soit là ce n'est qu'un
début
nous on souhaite que ça soit vraiment l'
amorce d'un printemps de luttes d'un
printemps social de l'it important
effort
il faudra qu'on continue bien évidemment
parce que là on le voit peut-être qu'on
commence à être à la fin d'une crise
sanitaire et quoique rien à rien n'est
sûr mais toujours est il sait que si le
gouvernement en tout cas continuent à
vouloir persister à nous imposer une
politique d'austérité une politique qui
a montré l'acheteur pendant la pandémie
qu'elle ne pouvait pas répondre aux
besoins de la population et bien un
effet la crise sociale la crise
économique risquent d'être mortifère
pour beaucoup d'entre nous alors nous
nous disons nous voulons un vrai plan de
rupture et ensuite un vrai
investissement de réinvestissement
justement pour pour aider une grande
partie de la population c'est à dire les
plus précaires les plus pauvres les
travailleurs les travailleuses pour
développer les services publics de la
fonction publique et arrêter surtout
arrêter tous ces licenciements
toutes les fermetures d entreprises et
toutes cédé l'occupent délocalisation
qui vont en effet avoir un effet
terrible notamment
sur ces salariés qui se retrouvent à la
rue du jour au lendemain on a
l'impression que la crise sanitaire si
vous voulez à la mis de côté toutes les
questions sociales qui a pu avoir
on a besoin que le gouvernement a
privilégié cette crise sanitaire au lieu
de se concentrer sur les réformes
sociales et les questions sociales
alors oui tout à fait un on a été
complètement et visibiliser pendant
pendant un an alors que justement les
questions sociales elles sont elles se
sont multipliées les préoccupations
sociales aussi et je dirais même que non
seulement le gouvernement a mis de côté
a fait en tout cas n'a pas voulu
répondre justement aux besoins de la
population qui ont été encore plus
frappante fac flagrant pendant cette
crise sanitaire
mais en plus il a continué ajustements a
mené sa mauvaise politique je donne un
exemple au niveau de la santé par
exemple où l'on on l'a vu on a besoin
d'un vrai investissement dans les
hôpitaux pour ouvrir des lits dans la
recherche pour les vaccins et au
contraire contrairement à ce qu'il a dit
d'ailleurs à ce qu'il a pu vouloir
marquer publiquement le gouvernement à
continuer à imposer donc cette politique
d'austérité à fermer des lits à à donner
de moins en moins de moyens aux
infirmiers aux infirmiers à tous les
personnels médicaux sociaux par exemple
et ça ce n'est qu'un exemple on a vu à
l'éducation nationale d'ailleurs les
personnels l'ont dit ils ont toujours
pas suffisamment de moyens pour pouvoir
enseigner d'une part pendant la crise
sanitaire mais de toutes manières après
sûr je le dis je les ai dit tout à
l'heure
la recherche c'est une catastrophe et
fait tous ces points là sont éminemment
important et on voit que
finalement le gouvernement par contre ce
qu'il a fait c'est qu'il a déversé des
milliards et des milliards à des grandes
entreprises qui elles ont continué par
contre certaines en tout cas à dégager
des profits sans demander aucune
contrepartie ça c'est un vrai problème
alors que dans le même temps les petits
commerçants les les hôtels et les
restaurants les bars tous les petits
auto entrepreneur e
en effet on un vrai souci et pour
certains c'est la mort assurée donc il
faut vraiment à équilibrer et c'est pour
ça que nous nous ce qu'on veut c'est
vraiment la solidarité l'égalité mais la
justice sociale la justice sociale parce
que là on en est loin c'est encore les
très riches qui continuent à un gouffre
et d'aider des bénéfices et des profits
au détriment des plus pauvres et on voit
mauvaise la réforme de l'assurance
chômage c'est aussi justement c'est
aussi l'objectif de ce rassemblement
s'est réclamé le retrait de cette
assurance chômage qu'est ce que vous
reprochez à cette réforme
cette réforme assurance chômage en fait
elle est faite
d'ailleurs ça a été dit et c'est le cas
pour faire des économies par le biais
six applique cette réforme d'assurance
chômage il faut une économie de plus de
3 milliards d'euros
faire une économie sur le dos des
précaires à des privés d'emploi c'est
une honte et donc du coup ils ont durci
les les régimes indemnitaires à tout cas
les les mesures pour permettre aux
personnes qui sont sont entrés caracter
ce soit qui n'ont pas travaillé tout le
temps et en plus cela on va le voir ça
va être flagrant parce que pendant cette
période de crise sanitaire
il ya beaucoup de personnes qui ont eu
leur contrat interrompu qui n'ont pas pu
trouver du travail
eh bien ces personnes là puisque
maintenant pour pouvoir avoir des
indemnités chômage
il va il va falloir travailler beaucoup
plus en fait
et bien finalement nous on a fait le
calcul il va y avoir à peu près ça va
toucher à peu près plus d'un million
sept de personnes qui seront privées
d'emploi qui ne pourront soit plus du
tout touché des nalité ou qui verront
leurs indemnités chômage décès alors
qu'au contraire il faudrait aider toutes
ces personnes et ces salariés qui à un
moment donné et c'est pas du fait de
leur choix on était dans l'obligation se
sont retrouvés sans travail ou en tout
cas ont eu des contrats qui ont été
interrompues et qui ne leur permettront
pas à cause de cette réforme de pouvoir
justement être indemnisées ça veut dire
que ça s'arrête des personnes qui vont
se retrouver sans aucune ressource suite
est malgré tout à cette crise sanitaire
qui qui ne leur incombe pas et enfin je
veux dire c'est les premières victimes
c'est bien justement les salariés et
ceux qui sont notamment en grande
précarité
merci beaucoup céline verzeletti d'avoir
répondu à nos questions rappelle que
vous êtes secrétaire confédérale de la
cgt vous l'aurez compris la convergence
des luttes
aujourd'hui c'est le mot d'ordre pour
pouvoir défiler lors de ce 1er mai
beaucoup de frustration vis-à-vis des
dernières de ne pas pouvoir de ne pas
pouvoir lui avoir défilé l'an passé à
cause du gobi 19 mai cette année
l'important c'est de marquer le coup
pour un réveil social pour un printemps
social pour la plupart des syndicats
présents ici merci d'avignon se
retrouvent de toutes façons tout allait
bien